the first doctors are recording leaving
more time and to talk about Lucky's
audience so yeah I passed doc I talked
about algorithms this talk I'm going to
talk about complexity again another
really really big topic I'm not going to
show you everything so here's the the
game plan I'm first going to reintroduce
you to SVP and and reintroduce you to
see VP really briefly and tell you about
the relationship between them then
hardness and hardness and then we'll end
with some some nice easy upper bounds
but mostly I interpreted the phrase
complexity of lattice problems as
meaning hardness of lattice problem so
that's mostly what I'll show you okay so
let's just remember the shortest vector
problem is defined as follows you have a
lattice there exists a shortest nonzero
vector in the lattice lambda1 is the
length of this vector and SBP is the
computational problem that asks us to
compute lambda 1 so I've sort of cheated
here a little bit in the previous talk I
define it as a search problem now I'm
defining it it's this decision problem
it's just in complexity land it's more
convenient to talk about the decision
they're not in fact equivalent in the
approximate version and the exact they
are okay and gamma s CP is the
approximate version so it asks you to
approximate this value up to some factor
camera the closest vector problem is
sort of the inhomogeneous variant of the
shortest vector problem so it's the
computational problem that asks you to
estimate the distance between some
target in the lattice and again we have
an approximate version of the problem
given by this approximation factor gamma
a larger gamma easier problem this is
just a very brief list of results for
CVP which are basically the same as STP
so just like SP P the exact problem can
be solved in 2 to the end time for
polynomial approximations we can do two
to the constant n where the Const
depends on the polynomial and we can get
2 to the N log log n over log and in
polynomial time so it's kind of like SVP
and like most of the results we know for
SVP we kind of know for CVP as well but
it seems a lot harder and like just one
thing that I want to mention is the
fastest algorithm for CVP is 2 to the
end time and I think that's tight I
don't think that's tight for SVP all
right we have these heuristic algorithms
that do a lot better for CVP I think
that's actually the right answer so we
think CVP is actually really quite a bit
harder than SVP
we don't sort of really know that though
in particular there's a formal sense in
which CVP is at least as hard as SVP
which is that SVP
reduces to CVP so if you give me a
faster algorithm for CVP it'll also give
you a faster route than for STP and this
is a do to that goal Drake Danyelle a
movie Safra and jean-pierre Seyfert and
it's a really really elegant simple
reduction goes as follows you consider
the following lattice I'll call L sub I
and L sub I is the lattice generated by
still the same basis B 1 through B n
except I should have an even coordinate
in my eye on my I faces factor so you
can either think of it like I doubled
the eyes basis vector or like I
restricted to the set where the eyes
coordinate is even same thing and then
you just stare at this for a second and
you realize that the distance from bi to
Li notice that bi is not in Li that's
kind of important the distance between
bi and Li is just the minimum length of
a lattice vector whose ice coordinate is
odd yeah which means that the lambda 1
is just the minimum over all I of these
distances why because a shortest nonzero
vector can't have all even coordinates
if all of its coordinates are even you
could divide by 2 and you'd get a
shorter vector so there must be at least
one odd coordinate so one of these
minimums has to be lambda long does that
make sense
very simple reduction it's also really
powerful
right because um this reduction
preserves both the dimension and the
approximation factor so like really
really really sort of no matter what
regime you care about whether it's
fine-grained or approximate or whatever
CVP appears to be at least as hard as
SVP I think you can fix that but I'm not
sure but that we need to have a Cynthia
okay so these are very well studied
problems here's a small subset of the
research that's been done on these
problems so I claimed that the these
problems are interesting from gamma
equals 1 to gamma equals exponential and
this is proof there's been tons of work
on this this is I'll actually show you a
decent fraction of these results in the
talk this is just to scare you
ok so no there's sort of warm-up result
let's prove that CVP is np-hard it's
it's a one slide proof it could have
been in carps original paper though it
wasn't so it's due to van Emde Boas in
1981
so quite early and the proof just goes
he kind of just remember the definition
of subset sum so remember subset sum is
an np-hard problem you're given n
numbers and one extra number s and you
look for a subset of the first n numbers
that sums to s right it's a yes instance
if they sum if there exists such a
subset it's a no instance if they don't
so to reduce this to CVP there's a very
very simple reduction you construct the
basis B which in its first where the
vectors in the first coordinates are the
a1 through a ends and on the bottom of
the matrix you just sort of put twice
the identity matrix and then your target
is a sort of the target value and then
the all ones vector right and now you
just stare at this for a second and you
notice that the distance between the
target and the lattice is square root n
if and only if there's a solution to
subset-sum right if there's a solution
to the subset-sum then that sort of
gives you a zero one vector in this
lattice that's at distance exactly
square root in a way right it'll have
some zeros and ones and these
coordinates and I'll have exactly s up
here but any other vector that doesn't
satisfy those exact requirements will be
distance larger than square root anyway
yeah this is not the original reduction
really matching the way that yes yes yes
this is not the original reduction but I
think it's the simplest yeah yeah yeah
it's on his website and you have to go
one page at a time you click like next
page and then you get then it reloads
yeah but it exists okay this result I
mean it's beautiful you know it could
have it could have been proven by carp
but it leaves some things to be desired
one problem with it is it doesn't give
us hardness of approximation and it
doesn't really seem plausible that you
could sort of modify it in some simple
way to get hardness of approximation
ideally we'd like to prove hardness of
approximation for polynomial
approximation factors I won't succeed
that today it also only works for CVP
we'd like to prove hardness of SVP and
it doesn't give us fine-grained hardness
so by fine grain hardness I mean I'd
like to rule out even a slightly faster
algorithm for CVP I'd like to rule out
two to the 0.99 and time algorithm
actually the reduction I already showed
you under a plausible complexity theory
conjecture that all that I'll mention
earlier it does rule out like a 2 to the
N over a hundred time algorithm for for
CVP so sort of that was already known
for for quite a long time but of course
what we really really want is a very
fine grain hardness their approximation
for SVP and in fact based on the results
that you'll see tomorrow these worst
case to adverse case reductions if we
could do this well enough is if we get
the approximation factor high enough and
the fine grain did enough this lower
bound sufficiently high then we would
get a statement like this we would say
no algorithm running into 2:128 time can
break this specific crypto scheme this
is this is way way beyond the reach of
what we know how to prove I mean this is
okay up to the fact that it uses actual
constants this is a much stronger
statement than P doesn't equal NP but we
land yeah unless the polymer collapses
yeah but maybe prove a reduction in some
other way or something I'm saying this
is the dream result yeah I'll show you
reasons why we don't expect to get it
like theoretical reasons in addition to
the fact that we haven't succeeded but
this is how I view this line of work
it's like our goal is to get as close to
a statement that would imply this as
possible and that means getting better
and better lower bounds for higher and
higher approximation factors for the
shortest vector problem that's our goal
and you can if you sort of don't want a
purely theoretical reason for this you
can also just think of this lower bounds
on SVP as lower bounds on the algorithms
that we actually use to break crypto and
practice which you'll hear a lot more
about from Martin yeah so before I show
you hardness of STP which is written
actually really quite difficult I'll
show you a better hardness result for
CVP we're still kind of in an easy land
so the way this works I have to reduce
from some problem so I'll reduce from
max to set remember max 2sat it's just a
to CNF so you're given a bunch of ores
of ends where each or just has two
elements with n variables and M clauses
and the goal is to figure out how many
of these clauses you can satisfy
simultaneously this is known to be
np-hard to approximate up to a constant
factor I'm saying this like it's no big
deal this is the PCP theorem it's a very
big deal
and the exponential time hypothesis
stood in Puglia zone Kotori is
one of the foundational sort of
fine-grained hardness results and I'm
lying a little bit here but basically it
says there's no two to the end over 100
time algorithm for this problem and a
more recent conjecture the gap
exponential time hypothesis due to die
nor and separately by Basin and I'm
forgetting though they're out there
there's no two to the N over 100 time
algorithm even to approximate this up to
some small constant factors say one
point zero one so this is so when I say
I'm going to prove hardness I mean I'm
gonna prove hardness under one of these
reasonable conjectures right because
otherwise well we don't know how to
prove hardness of anything okay so given
that max 2sat is is hard we can try to
reduce max 2sat to CVP here's how I'm
gonna do that here's so I'm going to
construct some basis and some target and
my basis is going to be the first basis
you would think of so the I the I throw
in the J's column I'm gonna put a 1 if
XJ appears in the highest cause and a -1
if not XJ appears in the ice claws 0
otherwise TI the target vector is less
obvious I'm gonna put 3 minus twice the
number of negated literals in the clause
not clear why that should work but
suppose you have some 0 1 vector and you
look at the lattice vector whose
coordinates are given by the 0 1 vector
Z and you look at the 8th coordinate of
that you stare at this for a second and
you see that it's going to be the number
of positive literal satisfied minus the
number of negative literals not
satisfied by Z if we view Z as
assignment to the variables are you guys
with me good then if we look at the
difference between B times Z and T in
the ice coordinate this is going to be
twice the number of satisfied literals
minus three and if you take the absolute
value of that you see that gives you one
if if one or two variables are satisfied
and three otherwise
oh sorry yes so good so a literal is
like a not x1 or an x3 and a variable is
just like the value of x1 or X or the
thing that you set the value to what
other things do I need to know satisfied
means that one of the literals is true
did I find everything ok
so the point is that like if so max 2sat
is to find an assignment which here I'm
writing is Z so zero one assignment or
true/false assignment to these variables
the goal is to figure out how many of
these clauses can be satisfied
simultaneously for approximate that
okay so if you combine all the
coordinates together you'll see that the
the squared norm it's always easier to
write the squared norm is equal to the
number of satisfied clauses plus nine
times the number of unsatisfied clauses
so in particular it's the vector is
closer if the assignment is sort of more
satisfying now one thing I did I cheated
here in CVP instances we care about all
possible coordinate vectors not just
zero one coordinate vectors but if you
stare at this for a second you'll
realize that all other vectors are at
least as far away as the zero one
vectors so this is this is kosher and
what this means is that the distance
between the target in the lattice tells
us exactly the maximal number of
satisfied clauses this is just another
NP hardness reduction but what's nice
about this reduction is first of all
maps constant factor to constant
approximation factors to constant
approximation factors so I actually have
proven NP hardness here of constant
factor approximate CVP for some you know
terrible constant approximation factor
like one point zero zero one or
something
and it also Maps n variables to n
columns in the basis which is also
really nice this is kind of what I mean
when I say fine-grained in particular if
you remember this gap ETH assumption
from before this means that under the
gap ETH assumption there's no two to the
N and over a hundred time algorithm that
solves say 1.01 CVP or whatever costume
you actually got there does that make
sense so like maybe this doesn't look
very impressive but it's like a lot more
impressive than saying there's no
polynomial time algorithm right we're
starting to get a better handle on the
actual complexity of the problem so the
state of the art is is quite a bit
stronger than this particularly the best
part is the approximation that we know
which is by daniele and others I thought
you're on that paper right right right
okay not by daniele gets n to the 1 over
log log N
approximation factor so this is known to
be np-hard and this is kind of a funny
function but the way that we think of
this look log log n is a constant
amongst friends so basically this is
almost polynomial right it's like and we
kind of think of this as like as good as
you can do without getting polynomial of
course what we really like is polynomial
I mean this is a difficult proof who
uses PCP machinery
I won't show it to you this is what I'm
calling in to the 1 over log log oh yeah
yeah yeah the factor yes yes you're
confusing about that see productions
polynomial yes yes yes this is np-hard
period the fine-grain hardness that we
know well under the exponential time
hypothesis we know that there's no 2 to
the N over 100 time algorithm for CVP I
actually just showed you that full proof
and I also showed you that into the gap
exponential time hypothesis there's no
approximation algorithm for CVP well we
actually know is quite a bit stronger
but you need to move to LP norms which
is a little disappointing
so remember the LP norm so the Euclidean
norm is you sum up all the coordinates
squared and then you take the square
root the LP norm is you sum up all the
coordinates raised to the P power and
you take the P through and use some
absolute values in there but we know
under the strong exponential time
hypothesis which is a stronger variance
of ETH that there's no 2 to the 0.99 n
time algorithm for exact CVP but in LP
norms for P naught and even integer and
one thing to remember is that 2 is not
an even integer so the norm that we care
about is l2 we have this very very
strong result I think for LP norms for P
naught and even integers we don't get it
for l2 but we go really close we also
know under a very non-standard
conjecture which I'm calling gap se th
we know that there's no 2 to the 0.99
time algorithm even to approximate CVP
up to some constant factor again this is
in this is in the LP norms and one
unfortunate thing is that the algorithms
don't work in these
Norm's so we have a two to the n upper
bound for one norm and we have a two to
the n lower bound for for all their
norms so this leads to my first open
question which is prove hardness of CVP
in the Euclidean norm that's as good as
we know in the LP norms and I think this
would be a big deal even outside of the
lattice community or the kapag rafi
community because I think this would be
the first fine-grained lower bound that
doesn't fall into like tight
fine-grained lower bound it doesn't fall
into like a small set of categories but
unfortunately sort of proven that
everything we know how to do so far does
it work and we even know that the
Euclidean norm is provably the easiest
norm and the sense that you can embed
the Euclidean norm in any other norm so
if you can solve CVP and any norm then
you can basically solve CVP in the
Euclidean norm so there are reasons to
think that this is a pretty hard problem
but it'd be a really big result there
are lots of examples where we know some
lower bound and some upper bound yeah
yeah so that's open problem number two
oh no that's not open problem number two
Oh problem number two is very difficult
it's proved hardness of approximating
CVP up to a polynomial approximation
factor I'll show you why we don't expect
to get too far with this later their
complexity theoretically ears but
getting like n to the 1 over 100 or
something we don't know why not to do
that oh I have an open problem coming
later that answers the notes question
okay so that's hardness of CVP and I
showed you that like actually proving
some basic hardness results of CVP is
quite easy right so it goes back to 1981
so it took us almost 20 years
venom day Boas asked in his original
paper is SVP np-hard and it took us
almost 20 years to find the answer I I
finally answered yes in 1998
unfortunately his reduction is
randomized and in fact all known
hardness
groups of SVP are still randomized so if
you care about the distinction between a
randomized reduction and the
deterministic reduction then formally
SVP still not known to be np-hard
this is in the Euclidean norm yeah so
and the own finiti norm things are nicer
and in all LP norms I think the status
is the same maybe for P like
asymptotically large or something and
then a very large number of people came
around so dad and Daniela and subhash
coat and this is a shy aviv came and
should prove that actually SVP is even
hard to approximate this was a long
series of works some really beautiful
results and i'll show you a little bit
of the techniques behind them or my
interpretation at least
so every hardness proof that I know of
for SCP I think of as trying to do the
following thing which doesn't work so
the idea is to use what's known as
canons embedding trick named after Ravi
Kanaan from 1987 the idea here is look I
have a matrix and I have a vector that's
my CVP input my SVP input has to be just
a matrix but like what's a matrix it's
just a list of vectors right so if I
want to get just a matrix I just sort of
a pen T to my list so I just sort of a
pen T it's more convenient to take minus
T to my my basis and I add this extra
coordinate and I put some number in
there just so that things type check and
everything still linearly independent so
this is like a really really natural
idea it's kind of the only thing I could
imagine doing and we can look at this
and see what it does so we can look at
the lattice generated by this basis B
Prime and its vectors look like this so
the first coordinate it sort of has
first end coordinates and a last
coordinate the first end coordinates
look like a lattice vector minus K times
the target and the last coordinate is K
times s right in particular this means
that if you have some lattice vector if
you have some vector in the original
lattice then you have the vector Y minus
T comma s in the new lattice which means
that essentially lambda 1 of the new
lattice is at most the distance you lose
this little factor s but if you have a
closed vector in your original lattice
then your new lattice will have a short
vector right but there's a problem with
this right does someone see the problem
the problem is that there are other
short vectors as well right not all
vectors in this lattice take this form
or in particular you can have K not
equal to plus minus 1 K minus 1 is sort
of the same thing you just get minus the
closest vector instead of plus the
closest vector actually it turns out
sort of because you can tune this s and
for some other more technical reasons
that the only actual problem is the k
equal
zero issue so k equals 0 corresponds to
short vectors in your original lattice
so clearly if your original lattice has
short vectors in it then this reduction
won't work right because my new lattice
will still have those short vectors and
I'll compute lambda 1 and it'll just
tell me your lattice has short vectors
in it which I already knew right so not
useful so the ideal solution to this
would be to say just assume that there
are no short vectors and this is not a
bad idea if you assume that there are no
short vectors that are shorter than the
distance then you've assumed that you
have a bounded distance decoding problem
up to constant factors and bound
distance decoding is very a very
important problem but we need to prove
hardness a bounded distance decoding in
order to make that useful
so the real solution is we make a much
weaker assumption we assume that there
aren't too many short vectors in our
original lattice and it turns out that
that's enough so in order to talk about
this a little bit more I'll have to
introduce some notation so I'm gonna
write n of L R for the number of vectors
of length that most are you know in a
lattice and I'll write Ln of LRT for the
number of vectors at distance at most R
from some target T ok so a number of
short vectors number of close vectors
and what we would like is the number of
short vectors to be much much less than
the number of close factors and I'll
show you why in the next slide so here's
Stickley there's many more close vectors
and short vectors and the reason why is
because we can use a trick do - Subhash
code known as sparse vacation which
works as follows it's closely related to
like these aitai lattices these Q Airy
lattices that Daniele talked about so we
can define the lattice L hat to be the
set of lattice vectors so still B prime
times Z so still things in the lattice
generated by B prime but we make a
restriction on the coordinates we say
that the coordinates have to satisfy
some linear equation mod Q so inner
product of
with some vector a has to be 0 mod Q
what is a will choose a randomly from
the appropriate set that should be Z Q
so if we choose a randomly then the
vectors in this L hat
they look essentially like we just
randomly we just randomly and
independently looked at each vector in
our original lattice and kept it with
probability 1 over Q and otherwise threw
it away this is obviously alive for a
lot of reasons in particular this is the
lattice and if I did that process I
wouldn't get a lot us but morally this
is what's going on and you can prove for
example here you you don't have pure
independence but you do have pairwise
independence which is already enough so
we have this procedure that sparsa Phi
is our lattice it takes our lattice and
it sort of randomly samples a q fraction
a 1 over Q fraction of the lattice
points so we take our value Q to be
roughly the number of closed lattice
vectors now we do this operation we'll
be left with roughly one closed lattice
vector remaining and if we had many many
more closed lattice vectors and short
lattice vectors then all the short
lattice vectors will be gone so this is
a sparse application trick right so if
the initial CBP instance had a bunch of
closed vectors and not too many short
vectors then the final CBP instance will
have no short vectors just close vectors
right and then we'll actually be able to
then the reduction will work
the original reduction will work so it
turns out that if you want to show
hardness of sv p if you sort of unwind
this it's suffice it to show hardness of
cv p with many more close vectors than
short vectors right if you can show that
an instance of cv p that has this funny
property is hard then you'll prove
hardness of sv p
so we need some way to increase the
ratio of closer vectors to short vectors
to do that we use a gadget I write like
to write my gadget with daggers so my
gadget will be B dagger and T dagger a
bassist and a target and I'm gonna use
my debt gadget in a sort of simple way
I'm gonna define L tilde to just be the
lattice generated by the this matrix B
zero zero B dagger and I'm gonna define
T tilde to be T dagger put under T of
course this is so this is the direct sum
of the two lattices a direct product if
you prefer right so lattice vectors and
L tilde just look like pairs of vectors
the first in LB and the second in my
gadget lattice and this equation is
slightly complicated but the idea is
that the number of short vectors in L
tilde should look roughly like the
product of the number of short vectors
in my original lattice and the number of
short vectors in my gadget lattice so
I'm hand waving aggressively here but
the rough idea if you have a short
vector because I'm not defining short
but if you have a short vector in L
tilde then it must come from a pair of
vectors one that's short in the original
and one that's short in the gadget right
and ditto for closed factors the number
of closed vectors is going to be
something like the product of the number
of closed vectors in the lattice with
the number of closed vectors in the
gadget so if we want the resulting
lattice to have many more closed vectors
than short vectors what we need is for
this ratio the number of closed vectors
in the gadget to the number of short
vectors in the gadget to be much much
larger than the number of sort of
annoying short vectors in our original
lattice and the number of short vectors
in our original lattice well we don't
really know what it is but it can't be
greater than two to the poly n because
if they're short vectors we should be
able to write them down and if we can
write them down then there are most two
to the poly n of them is that everything
check
suspicious yeah [ __ ] bones
yeah this is true you can bound the
number of short vectors yeah I'm just
being lazy good and daniele I think
coined the term locally dense lattice
for for these lattices so the idea here
is that these lasses have this
surprising property that there's some
ball in which there are many many
lattice points in fact significantly
more lattice points than there are in
the centered ball of the same radius so
their lattices that like happen to have
some strange dense region somewhere and
I believe all hardness reductions for
SVP use a gadget that satisfies this
property
most of them use additional properties
for various reasons but we did show
recently there's probably already known
to folklore that in fact any such gadget
already implies if you have such a
lattice than you get hardness of SGP so
these are hard to build I'm not going to
show you how to build them I'll just
sort of tell you what we've done and
yeah I think was an upper bound
okay and this ritual oh yeah so it has
to be larger than this which is at most
two to the poly yeah asymptotic notation
so we want this ratio to be larger than
two to some polynomial in the dimension
of our gadget lattice which already is
and dagger and actually formally we need
very slightly more than that or maybe
not so very slightly we actually need to
be able to throw some approximation
factor gamma down here so we actually
need our definition of short to be a
little more forgiving than our
definition of close and there's tons of
work on constructing these things the
current state of the art and the reason
we care about these things the larger
gamma you get the better hardness or
approximation your result you'll get
which maybe is intuitively kind of
appealing and if you get this polynomial
so normally like you might expect this
polynomial to be like n to the one third
or something like small but if you can
get this polynomial all the way up to a
linear which is provably optimal then
you can get a fine-grained hardeners to
roll for SVP you can prove that there's
no two to the epsilon n time algorithm
for SPP under gap eth which which i
showed you earlier and it turns out that
there do in fact exist L dagger that
kind of satisfy both these things
simultaneously so they have an
approximation factor or they have this
gamma factor that's larger than some
constant and they have a pond they have
exponentially many more close specters
and short vectors we showed this
recently is joint work with tabash and
particularly this implies that there's
no two to the epsilon n time algorithm
for like one point zero zero zero one
SVP under gap ETH so this is a sort of
hard-fought result and I think the moral
interpretation is that we're not
completely out of the ballpark on RSVP
algorithms right like this tells us that
we don't expect to find a two to the
square root n time algorithm or
something something that just totally
different than everything else we
already done like ideally what we'd like
to show is that you know this 4/3 to the
N over two or three halves the N over
two or something is the right answer
um but this is what we actually know how
to prove and interestingly the way that
we do this goes through so we were only
able to do this recently because we used
a result that was proven very recently
by blood dude so let's show the lattice
with exponentially many vectors that all
had minimal length so if I do showed
that there are lattices with large
kissing number you might remember from
my previous talk that the kissing number
featured prominently in the study of
saving algorithms and I think that this
relationship is really extremely
interesting the fact that our best lower
bounds and our best upper bounds both go
through the kissing number kind of
suggests that maybe we're doing
something right because like obviously
our goal is to make the upper bounds
match the lower bounds and if they both
use the same stuff then that's good okay
for the l2 norm we do in fact the l2
norm is non-uniform because I don't know
anything about this lattice but for
other norms for P larger than 2.14 we
don't
because our gadget is the integer
lattice okay so for the Euclidean norm
the best result that we know is is what
I just showed you there's no two to the
epsilon and time algorithm for a
constant factor approximate SBP for some
terrible constant approximation for LP
norms just like for CVP for SBP we know
a lot more we know very strong hardness
really note there's no two to the C
times n time algorithm for SBP where C
depends on the norm in this way it's not
clear at all if if this is sort of the
right answer because SBP in these norms
is is very poorly studied but I guess
the point is that we can prove very
strong hardness results just not in the
right norm and this is based on joint
work with division hawk who are both
here you've been sitting next to each
other and with Sascha golovanov and the
open problem that's obvious is to get
better fine-grained hardness results for
the Euclidean norm so this is like one
of the Holy Grails I think and I'll even
ask a really really bold question which
is can we get matching upper and lower
bounds under just a conjecture a
geometric conjecture again I'm kind of
excited about the fact that somehow the
kissing number appears multiple times so
I think this might plausibly be maybe
kind of sort of doable which is exciting
yeah
from work because the construction of
the lettuce that uses a very different
format
yeah I don't know Danielli probably
knows better than me I still head the
local dance yeah so the local again
started it was not expected a race fans
buried somewhere in there and the friend
number those prime numbers can be
turning to the coroner's lab design you
use that so if you do that you know see
night I suffer the reduction was
randomized with one-sided higher or from
the specification is introducing random
in session and error on the other side
the so it becomes suicided ever but the
subsequent work is going back to
one-sided error or an essentially other
center over there locally dense love the
main issue right yeah if we can find
these gadgets deterministically then
then we'd have daniele proof this thing
maybe not maybe need a couple more
properties of the local events ladders
just locally don't ya then we have
deterministic
[Music]
but yeah I really think this is
plausible which I'm excited about open
problem number four which I thought I
put earlier oh I'm gonna fix that
immediately that is bad
do you have to yeah yeah
okay so open problem number four is to
find algorithms for s CP and CV P in the
LP norms so Daniele mentioned this
earlier I think this is an interesting
question just on its own as I said dvash
has a result in this area together with
priyanka Mukerji for the Alan Finney
norm but this is really like largely on
unexplored territory and it's
interesting in its own right and I also
think it's just interesting because of
these lower bounds like matching upper
and lower bounds are rare things and
here we have no idea if we have them
because we haven't really thought about
the problem that much
and number five I think these locally
done sob locally dense lattices are
really very beautiful objects on their
own I think they're worthy of study
independent of hardness of SBP
particular we can imagine proving upper
and lower bounds on these things and
like for some norms like our
constructions are very natural it's
plausible they might be optimal so I
think these are interesting fun things
to study if you're into that kind of
thing
so now I'm gonna say a little bit about
hardness or approximation
unfortunately these the way these proofs
go you can sort of either say a little
or a lot I think so I'm gonna say a
little so we proved part is for constant
factor approximation for bad constant
factor approximation the idea which was
originally due to Sebastian then was
improved in by a Cheyenne da Dada is to
boost the approximation factor imagine
this idea was actually around before
though the idea is to take the tensor
product of the lattice with itself so
this means like you sort of replace your
basis matrix but while you do replace
your basis matrix by the tensor product
of the basis matrix with itself so like
every entry and the new basis matrix is
the product of two entries in the
original basis matrix one issue with
this is that it blows up the dimension
so you start out with in n by n matrix
you end up with an N squared by N
squared matrix just doing this once but
the good thing is that it maps the
shortest vector to be linked their
respective to the length of the shortest
vector squared which means that your
approximation factor gets squared and
here swarming in the audience this this
statement here is the intuition for why
this should work it's not entirely true
if this were true then I would be done
proving hardness approximation for
larger approximation factors but this is
actually very false in general so the
whole game here which is a difficult
game is to find lattices or find
variants of ten suring that make this
fact true but I'm sort of just not going
to go into that at all because it's a
its its own world just answering it the
specification
I don't think to get this no that's not
true I mean it is true if one if you do
not miss is in dimensions not less than
40 you're not going to find explicitly
an example where this muscle is spider
doesn't miss Square where no their
explicit example itself to a lot of
satisfy this ourself two lattices with
the lambda 1 equals square done it
doesn't get squared yeah yeah in fact it
could it's much worse than squared it's
like squared divided by your Diner
yeah it's falsified some are taking a
sub it's possible that you could
reinterpret it that way I mean it's not
what they looked at very specific
properties of the lattice yeah maybe
looking back on that paper homogeneity
constraint oriented relative software in
one that
I don't think it matters so I'm just
saying that the lambda 1 squares
whatever whatever it is that that makes
sense right
I mean it's not true but it makes sense
and then the approximation factor would
square right you're closing the coming
metric for a second if it is always true
nucleus that's messy yeah
so using these ideas you can get MP
hardness for any constant approximation
factor that was originally proven vise
abash and that's like a modular the fact
that this lam the one thing isn't true
that's kind of immediate from this right
because I can just I can tensor as many
times as I want
I'll go from dimension n to n squared
and then I do it again I'll get into the
four and then into the eighth etc but I
can do this a constant number of times
I'll still be polynomial so that's okay
and we can get as large a constant as we
want the have even reggae a sort of
orthogonal result they showed that
there's no polynomial time algorithm for
n to the one over log log n as CP but
not under a polynomial time reduction it
the reduction the running time of the
reduction is is much much larger so the
only show that there's no polynomial
time algorithm if there are no sub
exponential time algorithms for for NP
if that makes sense
and this just become this just comes
from this tensor Inc thing you have two
tens are a super constant number of time
so you don't get a polynomial time
reduction but you'll notice this is the
same approximation factor that we have
for SVP it's just a weaker hardness
result so a natural looping question
which have been node thinks is within
reach is to prove just straight NP
hardness for n to the one over log log n
STP so in other words just extend what
we already know for CVP to SVP I don't
maybe but now it has more thoughts on
how this would go maybe would adapt PCP
machinery or something but yeah I know
it thinks this is within reach and maybe
you can coax him he's been known to give
$100 the people who solve problems maybe
you can Kosovo's we can have an auction
later okay the other question is to
prove better fine grained hardness
approximation in particular this tensor
ring is very very much not fine-grained
in the sense that just doing it one time
take
so dimension from end to end squared so
you can think of that as taking hardness
from like two to the order n two like
two to the order square root n which
like is we're already really not happy
with we'd like to prove exponential
hardness of these problems so I think a
really interesting question is whether
we can boost the approximation factor
without squaring the dimension maybe
even not even in a polynomial time
reduction you can use 2 to the N over a
hundred time I'd still be happy and I
think any new idea here would be
interesting anything that's not ten
Tsering would be really really
interesting even if it doesn't give new
results because this is sort of the as I
see it kind of the new frontier in
particular this is how we get closer to
this unachievable goal of proving that
crypto schemes are actually two to the
hundred twenty-eight bit hard we have to
get higher and higher approximation
factor so right now we just don't know
how to go higher than like 1.0 one
okay so now I'm going to show a couple
upper bounds which from from this
perspective or really lower bounds for
lower bounds in particular I'll show you
why we don't expect to prove MP hardness
for arbitrarily large polynomial
approximation factors say what I mean by
upper bounds here I give a whole talk on
algorithms and usually when you say
upper bounds you mean algorithms I think
what I mean here is I'm gonna place
these problems in complexity classes so
I'm gonna use you know non-standard
definitions of algorithms essentially
and the first main result I think in
this area is due to Shafi you know dude
back in 1998 they showed that an
all-powerful provers say shoppi
can convince bounded verifier like
myself that the distance between the
target and the lattice lies in some
range where the gap in this range is
between is a factor of root log n over n
so that's kind of the approximation
factor and notice that so one step in
this proof is easy remember Shafi as you
know is all-powerful so if she wants to
prove to me that the distance with a
target in the lattice is at most R she
just exhibits a closer vector right this
is easy this is saying see VPS in NP
would be the language here the difficult
part is going in the other direction
right so like stop and think about it
for a second like how would you show
someone that there's not a closed vector
in a lattice right it's kind of like
saying that a formula is not satisfiable
or something you know even those
shoppies all-powerful it's not clear
that she convinced little of me that
such statements were true and what this
means why I call this a lower bound for
lower bounds is it means that we don't
expect to prove NP hardness for root n
over log and CDP or also root n over log
and SVP because if we did then the
polynomial hierarchy could collapse
which basically means like complexity
theorists would be very upset with you
so we don't expect to do this
deal with it like that you um okay
so let me show you the protocol it's
it's really quite beautiful and quite
simple the idea is so you start out with
the CVP instance right so we have a
lattice and we have a target I've drawn
my target sort of far away from the
lattice because the difficult thing for
shoppi to prove is going to be that we
are in fact far away from the lattice so
how is how are we going to do this well
first I'm gonna consider not just the
target point itself but all shifts of
the target point by lattice vectors so
these are shifts of the target point by
lattice vectors and I'm going to imagine
a ball of radius R over to around every
such point and here's what I'll do I'll
pick one of these points randomly you
have to be careful about what you mean
by picking randomly from accountably
infinite set but you can make this
precise I'll pick one of these points
randomly say this one so I pick this
ball and then I just sample a uniformly
random vector T Prime in this ball it's
not clear why I'm doing this yet it's
just because I like doing such things
but it'll work and so that's one sort of
thing that I can do another thing that I
can do is I can pick a uniformly random
vector in a ball around a lattice point
so these are sort of the two different
games I can play I can either pick a
uniformly random ball around a ship of T
or I can pick from a uniformly random
ball around a shift of a lattice point
so now what I will do is I'll tell Shafi
hey here's my point and Shafi will tell
me whether it came from the blue set or
the red set whether it came from whether
it's close to the target or it's close
to the lattice that's all shop he does
and notice that if the distance is in
fact larger than R then shoppi can
always distinguish between the blue set
in the red set they're destroying right
so she always knows whether I chose
bluer around that's just I guess
triangle inequality
on the other hand if T happens to be
very close to the lattice and if you
don't know much about high dimensional
geometry of the where this root log and
over N factor comes in will not be clear
but if T happens to be close to the
lattice then these two sets have to
overlap quite considerably and this root
n over log n is just sort of how this
works out in high dimensions so no
matter what shop he does if I pick you
know this point here she's not going to
be able to tell me whether it came from
the blue set or the red set because it's
equally likely alright so this is a sort
of funny notion of proof or the way
strophe proved something to me is she
just proved that she could do something
she didn't argue about it good
so actually this is a statistical zero
knowledge proof in case you know what
that means this is a little stronger
than then I showed you but the moral of
the story is for approximation factors
above square root n over log n we don't
expect to prove NP hardness so there's a
similar upper bound result similar the
proofs not oh I didn't fix the
approximation factor here but dorita no
dad showed that square root and CVP is
in Co NP so I just showed you Co a.m.
and the reason that was a co a.m.
protocol I didn't even define Co mm but
Co em involves me talking to sha fee and
ChopShop you're responding a co MP
protocol is Shafi doesn't have time to
talk so she just sends me an email right
um and so Dury I know dad showed how to
prove that this distance is at most R
dat most R over square root n log and
shouldn't be there in a non-interactive
way non-interactive no randomness and
the moral of this story is that if we
proved NP hardness of square root n CVP
R squared and s VP the polynomial
hierarchy would still collapse but it
would be like even worse so we like very
much don't expect to prove this it's
also just a beautiful
so I want to mention it there's actually
a new line of work by Catarina and
Manila sand Giorgos who is not here and
that's not a picture of him doesn't have
a picture online if you google him this
is what you get Daniel wicks his advisor
but they they prove that for an
approximation factor SVP is in PPP which
means we really don't expect to prove NP
hardness of NS VP because otherwise
christos papadimitriou will be unhappy
so in summary we know quite a bit I
think I've shown you at least mentioned
sort of everything on the left side of
this and you'll be hearing about the
crypto applications of SVP in future
talks so a lot of the results that I've
shown on this crazy scary slide will
actually be part of this workshop but I
guess like the the 30,000 foot summary
is that we know hardness for almost
polynomial factors we know fine-grained
hardness for like near exactly small
constant factor approximation and we
don't expect hardness for root and over
log n so you know you might guess what
the open problem would be one obvious
open problem is to do something between
this upper bound in this lower bound
been this way for quite a long time and
you know so we know nothing that
suggests that we can't prove enter the 1
over 100 hardness and we also know
nothing that rules out the possibility
that maybe for like n to the 1/4 or
something CVP lies in your favorite
complexity class so I think this is
so if you assume something a crazy
conjectural into the label covers yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there is yeah I
don't
yeah I don't understand this result so I
didn't talk about it yeah that's what I
mean yeah so there-there is in fact the
result in this area that I did not
include which is an end to the 1/6
hardness under non-standard conjecture
but I still think this soap and I think
in particular upper bounds
you know the polynomial hierarchy
doesn't end at Co NP or Co a.m. it goes
up for a while so one could maybe
plausibly expect to find additional
upper bounds to explain why we seem to
be stuck let me be we're not stuck s
closest to end to the one out minus
epsilon cos tons less than one out yeah
I mean actually I mean there there are
some things that you do to I guess
upcoming work with many there there are
some things that you can do in this
regime but like
I mean I don't know has anyone thought
about you know going seven levels up in
the bottom hierarchy or something like I
think it's plausible that sort of can be
explored more
okay so I'm almost done let me just list
open problems for you be labeled with
the skiing notation right so I actually
ended up being sorted not intentional
but we have some hard problems which are
to prove better hardness results I guess
I'm particularly to get tight fine grain
hardness for exact GDP and the Euclidean
norm type fine grain hardness for exact
SVP in the Euclidean norm and hardness
for polynomial approximation factors so
all of these are open and seem quite
difficult and potentially easy open
problem of course these are just my
guesses I don't know how hard these
problems will be because I haven't
solved them but potentially easy problem
is to think about better algorithms in
the LP norm I think that's not a very
explored so I recommend people try and
then a bunch of medium problems there's
a geometric question about a better
understanding of locally dense lattices
there's the nodes question of proving NP
hardness of n to the 1 over log log NS u
P so matching what we know for CVP
there's fine grain hardest approximation
which I think might be not too hard for
CVP but probably very hard for SVP but
what do I know
and there's coming up with an upper
bound somewhere in the regime no matter
where we don't know much and they think
that's it guess I'm on the job market
yeah
and other questions
history yeah you see you mentioned a lot
about the kissing number yeah
so you defined it
yeah so it's it's the number of the
number of points you can put on a sphere
such that so say a unit sphere such that
all points are at least distance one
away from all the points yeah so that's
that's the same thing except the point
should be shortest points in the lattice
yeah they have to have to belong to the
lattice so yeah it's the number of
shortest points is easier way to say it
yeah and they're not known to be the
same number
yeah so let's do very recently careers
in training 18 there's a major
breakthrough that there are lattices
with exponential kissing under
yeah like to date over 50 or something
like this
algebraic geometric codes use often my
knowledge of
so I have a question about his diary
well I guess it's from a couple years
ago anyone okay yeah
are there any of updates on this well I
need one update in 2016 introduction
there are things that aren't included
but I think the short answer is not
really not much you can tell me if I'm
wrong
well the question is have there been
like significant advances and reductions
between worst case lattice problems in
the past four years yeah yeah I mean you
can see that this is danyele's diagram a
lot of hems
[Applause]
[Music]